en ukraine avec un bilan des victimes
civiles qui s'alourdit chaque jour
davantage avec ses bombardements russes
on dénombre 27 morts à mehr et fars près
de la ville assiégée de karkhiv mais les
grandes agglomérations
dont pieve ne sont pas tombés dans cette
région le fond semble être jolie depuis
plusieurs jours autour de la capitale
les ukrainiens attendent l'ennemi de
pied ferme c'est un reportage sur la
ligne de front à 15 kilomètres de kiev
des envoyés spéciaux de france 24
johnattan watch et james andris
ces soldats ukrainiens nous emmène sur
leurs positions au nord-est de kiev
nous sommes autorisés à filmer à une
condition ne pas donner d'éléments
précis sur leur localisation
sur des centaines de mètres des
tranchées et des abris fraîchement
creusée
cette zone est très importante car nous
sommes seulement à 15 km des faubourgs
de kiev et l'aéroport de boryspil n'est
pas loin
les russes pourraient l'utiliser pour
faire atterrir des renforts et prendre
la capitale
accueillera la défense s'organise pour
repousser les colonnes de chars ennemis
ces soldats dispose pour cela d'une arme
redoutable
ces lignes de défense peuvent paraître
rudimentaire mais c'est surtout grâce à
ces missiles antichars que les forces
armées ukrainiennes parviennent à
contenir la poussée russe sur ce front
située au nord est de kiev
un armement de plaintes fournis par les
pays occidentaux et qui a maintes fois
fait ses preuves ces dernières semaines
âgé de 59 ans ilitch a repris du service
pour défendre son pays
j'ai été formé à l'époque soviétique
alors j'ai rejoint l'armée pour leur
faire profiter de mes compétences qu'on
a quittés mais le dombass ont été
attaqués j'ai senti que je devais
combattre alors j'y suis allé je suis en
pleine forme je ne sens pas mon âge
c'est cadeau pour les moscovites
vous accueillir avec sa
machine
vladimir poutine rêvait d'une guerre
éclair qui mènerait ses troupes tout
droit au coeur de la capitale mais
l'effort sucré nien bloquent depuis
plusieurs semaines l'avancé des blindés
russes la bataille de kiev ne fait sans
doute que commencer
ailleurs sur le fond